this is just completely
predictable but also disastrously
humiliating
we have now learned that a close ally
per cnn
of georgia republican congresswoman
marjorie taylor greene participated
participated in the january 6th
riots in washington dc and was
among those who ultimately made their
way
into the building we've been covering
marjorie taylor green
as one of quite a few trumpy
radical right-wing members of congress
that won solely because of
their support of donald trump and
marjorie taylor green in particular has
been promoting all sorts of conspiracies
and dangerous ideas she encouraged the
idea
untrue idea that the election was
somehow stolen by joe biden from donald
trump
she tweeted that those who broke into
the capital weren't even really
republicans they were
antifa dressed up as trump supporters
but unfortunately
a guy named anthony aguero a
conservative live streamer
activist and associate of marjorie
taylor greens
is on video saying he was among those
who entered
it wasn't done by antifa it was really
pro-trump republicans who did it
he said quote on video we were all there
it was not antifa
and it was not black lives matter it was
trump supporters that did that yesterday
i'm the first to
admit it being one myself i walked
amongst all those
people this is a close associate of
marjory taylor greens green and aguero
worked closely together on immigration
related issues the border wall they went
to pro-trump rallies together
a bunch of videos have since been
deleted but marjorie taylor-green has
called aguero amazing and a friend
and aguero called green one of my
closest friends
this is an associate of marjorie taylor
greens who was an activist with marjory
taylor green
who is at the trump riots and
participated in
the trump riots now will there be any
repercussions for marjorie taylor green
as a result of this i don't think so
i don't think so at this point we have
seen that you can essentially get away
with anything in the republican party
without having to resign without having
repercussions
it was even shocking to me that marjorie
taylor greene was stripped of her
committee assignments because of
uh the things that that she said in the
aftermath of the january 6th
uh riots but uh the the only way out of
this is she has to be soundly defeated
in 2022. now i'm already seeing
all sorts of very confident
uh statements that marjorie taylor green
is facing a bloodbath for re-election in
2022
she's going to be soundly defeated it's
going to be humiliating she's going to
be made a one-term congresswoman
let's seize up on that a little bit it's
not totally clear to me that that's
guaranteed to be the way that it goes
there's a bunch of different things that
can happen
one is we don't know what the political
tide will be at the national level in
2022
it could be that this sunday donald
trump at his cpac speech
announces he's running in 2024 and it
could be that
something happens between now and 2022
and donald trump personally campaigns
for marjorie taylor green and she gets
herself reelected i think anybody
assuming she doesn't
is not thinking uh empirically at this
point in time
the other thing we have to remember for
those of us hoping for a humiliating
defeat for marjorie taylor green
in november of 2022 is that if it's
obvious that she has no shot she may
just
say she's not running for reelection to
save face she may say you know what
i did my one term unfortunately because
of the fake news and the socialist
democrats and all of this canceled
culture
they are limiting my ability to do
anything so i'm going to be able to
better work for the people
by going back to georgia and doing who
the hell knows what
some lobbying gig for all i know i don't
know but
that is also a sort of escape pod
that if if it's abundantly clear she's
going to lose she also just may not run
for re-election so
we just want her gone i don't care if
she loses in 2022 or chooses not to run
but if you're just assuming she's going
to get soundly defeated
i think you're getting a little bit a
little bit ahead of yourself there
okay we have a fantastic program today i
do want to remind you i will be
live streaming cpac on sunday the final
speeches at the
conservative political action conference
which will include a speech by former
president donald trump
possibly to announce his 2024 candidacy
i hope you will join me
sunday for the rare weekend live stream
on youtube twitch and facebook but we
still have a fantastic
program for you today and we'll continue
right after this
send me your thoughts about the marjorie
taylor green situation you can find me
on twitter
at deepakman if you are anything like me
you probably aren't thrilled with the
idea of going into
a doctor's office right now and
thankfully there's a practical
and affordable way to take control of
your health
and get personalized care from the
comfort of your home it's a service
called
steady md they're one of our sponsors
you take a quiz
you get matched with a licensed primary
care physician
who understands your health needs you
have a one hour video call with your new
doctor
you establish a meaningful relationship
with them and after that
your doctor is available to you anytime
by text phone or video chat this is not
a random doctor on call
each doctor at steady md has a limited
number of patients so they actually have
time
to listen to you you get the personal
attention that you deserve
they can do almost everything an
in-person doctor can do
perform medical evaluations talk to you
about health concerns send prescriptions
to your home or local pharmacy
and anything they can't do online
they'll quickly set you up with
an in-person provider to do things like
blood tests as an example
you don't need insurance it's only 99
bucks a month with
no other fees or copays there are so
many
practical advantages to using steady md
for primary care
and it's also so much more affordable
go to steadymd.com slash pacman to take
the free quiz
see which doctor is right for you i took
their quiz they matched me with
a doctor who specializes in my
particular health needs and situation
the doctor they gave me
is a really perfect fit for me and my
medical needs there's no risk no
commitment to get started
just click the link right underneath
this video